I love the way what was the football
player and I said cap took a knee and
that was how we were asking
Malcolm Jay health he says we ride
peacefully peacefully peacefully for
iving but that wasn't that was the best
way to do it Matt in your eyes and me
the knee I think is that the best time
to do it because I think you know
there's a lot of cameras on us during
the national anthem you know so I the
the movement was hijacked by the
President and say what you want in the
NFL owners a good old boys club and if
you want to stand with the good-old-boy
Club you know what that is
they're all really riders one minority
yes right so he's you know so they
hijacked a peaceful movement saying that
you're disrespecting the flag in the
country and it was never about that we
were just we use the the the moment of
the anthem as our vehicle of protest you
know we took a knee at that time because
we knew cameras they ordered cap to new
camera the point was that it was
controversial
it's supposed to be contraband it was
peaceful and it was quiet it was but you
know what it was is a lot of Americans
didn't see it as bringing light to
police brutality they saw this
disrespecting the flag so let's say you
own a team or your Roger Goodell ratings
went down 20% mm-hmm now your tie my
bottom dollar so that so then what do
you do like if you're calling traffic
because you have went hey dude instead
of taking a knee because we know the
message in the display of the flag but
for whatever reason a lot of America is
[ __ ] stupid
they find that this reppin they're not
tuned in we're down 3% could you have
written all the name though no no no no
beaten to me all the 20% that went down
I want you to educate yourself
understand why he's taking those 20 you
can't those 20 percent they're not
they're more than [ __ ] right the point
I get into Mia where I knew I said she
can't say [ __ ] but I solidified my
thinking when when I started seeing
veterans say we understand why cap is
kneeling I don't feel disrespecting this
was all colors alright I think all of us
with a brain realized it wasn't
disrespect the right like that it was
about police brutality but then you have
the other what a present hijacked the
President did his dog was the thing he
hijacked to call them all son of a
[ __ ] and people are there's so that
the problem is there such as so many
followers in this world
sheep yeah Jack there's not enough
leaders and you know individual thinkers
you know so that president hijacks the
movement and everyone jumps on the train
and went away from what it was about
presentations
never underestimate never underestimate
the virtue for Americans have something
called sacredness there are certain
things that are sacred to a middle fuzzy
fund with the flag explaining so so it's
the same thing it's like cutting up the
American flag to clean and to clean your
bathroom to clean your toilet to use as
a rag for your toilet it may not be
legal it may not be illegal but for
Americans or your Isis it is yeah
having having a few taken by a
battleground where a sacred battleground
or something that's part of American
history they do always studies people go
so we have a deep sense of what's sacred
and what's not but we pick and choose
though because Budweiser throws the flag
you're not supposed to wear the flag on
a t-shirt you're not supposed to wear
the flag in a bunch of different ways
but we pick and choose what you want
because this America because the great
thing about the flag is says I can burn
the flag if I want and that's when you
might beat up yes but that's the
strength of this country that is the
great strength that the idea that you
can do remember you have the right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness think about how general that
is think about it for a second you're
not you have the right you have the
right of happiness right and then and
that was the point is that maximum
freedom was was allotted you have a a
certain that's true but what's beautiful
about the time fathers now remember when
they wrote it to that's what's the IRA a
great irony of the great experiment in
married 90s that stays is that they
wrote the Constitution men who owned
slaves men who were racist they wrote
the Constitution what's beautiful about
the Constitution and the Bill of Rights
though is that very document and that
Bill of Rights and the thinking that
went around gave birth to feminism
humanism racism the notion of racism so
the doctrine and that doctrine and those
principles were used to emancipate
emancipate people worldwide because you
can't argue with no no you guys don't
read sapiens by you Val Harare about
yeah no I mean I obviously haven't done
as much research as you so I would never
claim to know as much but to me when you
have stuff like you said that the
Constitution was root
written by slave owners policing was
started as slave Wranglers I mean so we
need look at those two things they found
ever policing was also used as as a way
to resolve conflict the courts were but
remember there was always criminals in a
society you you are gonna have murder
criminals don't have a color bad bad
doesn't have a color you mean so you do
need a police force for the I don't
agree with completely because they want
perso police like Sumalee
that's just too many people that are
just bad people to live like that you
know well that's gonna help if you go no
police or Lord gangsters well it's
correct but also the people are gonna
suffer those people the minorities yeah
the rich people are gonna hire private
security we're gonna be fine that's
talked to south and I say where were you
and is that what would you give
Kaepernick a job because I think the
Seattle Seahawks trying out bring him on
the team it's tough man I'm pretty sure
Seattle's gonna bring you in because
here's the other thing if Russell Wilson
did it they're gonna listen a little
more I think the timing of CAP doing it
I think if this was super cap Super Bowl
run when he was the most explosive
dynamic quarterback on the planet it
went but a lot of people had their first
thing was well he wasn't playing no more
he was this is kind of his way mahomes
does it there's a dirty house right well
I mean I think I don't know who started
that video but Patrick mahomes was on it
in the next day Roger Goodell responds
with you know a written state well hold
up it was past mahomes it was that the
Jags are running back say Quan Barclay
from the Giants young Oh Jackson they're
the faces League and they sent you did
you know this now they sent Roger
Goodell video saying you better do
something the next day on it this fool
was on FaceTime with everybody I would
have respected Roger Goodell so much
more if he would have said he said the
NFL made a mistake
you should have apologized to Kaepernick
yeah why yeah I would to me Rodriguez Oh
Goodell would have went so much and you
know I don't know I think he was gonna
go down in history yeah as as a positive
figure in this key is gonna be known
more for his
in his actual plane like he's if he
would have just placed it he would have
made a good football player he's gonna
go down as a historical figure for what
he started in this is one thing I want
to touch on too is the knee like the
need to me doesn't mean very much
anymore now because you see one day you
see cops taking a knee but then later on
TV will see cops when people's answer to
peaceful protests like the knees been
hijacked now - now the NFL wants to
allow or if you want to need now you
didn't like that's [ __ ] she loves
exactly even more years ago you
blackballed a man for peacefully taking
a knee for police brutality not to
disrespect the flag not to disrespect
any race nation creed color he wasn't
doing he took a knee to bring attention
to police brutality to minorities not
sure what happened think about this
think about how they handled this think
about this doing this in and when the
league starts up which don't miss any
games is me crowd think if they did this
today in this culture they made guys who
take any stay in the locker room can you
give me can you give me a refresher
course when when cap took the knee
I remember being controversial what
happened to him as a player did they
suspend him nothing nothing so he can
tell the time but he was blackballed and
then yeah and then you can shed some but
then I didn't last year remember that
guy were gangin we're gonna give him
opportunity he was this is such [ __ ]
figure we're giving opportunity we're
gonna have 20 Scouts there we're doing
Atlanta Atlanta Falcons headquarters so
he gets in the Hanuma contract no you
gotta sign this they say what we didn't
agree to this my lawyers have listed
over this is something new out of fine
to the fine print base he's saying you
can't sue us down the road whenever
happens basically taking away all his
rights that if he was shunned from the
league kitchens even super you know God
knows how much money but if he signed
that contract all that goes so that's
why he did a private workout at a
different place yes last minute cuz they
said he balls out so then yeah he played
whatever because it gave him a chance
and you did this and he was wearing a
t-shirt that had a fist I went yeah I
did but also jay-z went bad on cuz jay-z
did people out people don't know this
jay-z's an advocate for the NFL he's
their liaison now he's kind of like you
who work for the NFL right how you are
then be
another like I don't know if J went bad
on him I think I think he's disappointed
I don't I think the only thing that that
I might miss with him when he said
disappointed J said we're fast taking a
knee I think that's what pissed everyone
over Jessie he were past taking a knee
and that's where the black community was
really kind of bothered by what he said
but I give JZ pross because to me we
can't change nothing from the outside
like we finally have someone who for us
that has a seat at that table there's a
that is a 99.9 percent white table but
we have someone that speaks us they came
from our culture that has our background
that has our DNA in us that he that has
enough power now to possibly change
things so JZ
and the one thing you know everyone
always wants to know what are you doing
with like J move [ __ ] behind the needle
you know where's so much about
self-promotion like look what I did a
protest let me announce pictures and
show people and it's like to me that I
mean that's a whole nother side but I
think some people are just doing it to
put on Instagram to show but you know
jay-z is someone who is behind the
scenes pushing buttons calling I don't
even want to make a mistake of who we
called I think he called the governor of
Minnesota or some higher up ranking a
Minnesota like these police need to be
the other three police need to be
arrested and I think the day after they
were arrested you know I mean so Jay is
moving stuff for our culture he's just
not self promoting so I think he says
that was like he takes a lot of [ __ ]
have you ever realized what Kanye West
has done no dude how many people's
college education he's paid for funds
that he started you know but like I said
I think where the black culture lost
Kanye was because he was supporting
someone who spewed hate like I said
Trump kind of could post or you make him
a pariah like because you have to
understand like if he if if if you know
Kanye growing in from the beginning he
was always it wasn't so much Pro black
it was just for the betterment of our
movements our you know I mean our he was
so much for our people and he was a
voice of our people and he's gonna go
down as one of the greatest minds you
know as I've horse historical figure you
know I mean but I think the fact that he
teamed up with Trump when us who pay
attention and all we want is love and
peace although it's not ideal when you
when you team up with someone who
projects so much hate the the black
Mina's gonna turn their back on you II
was off the met then too though we got
to take down the guys right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]